but they should be saying you know when
we get this under control we're not just
going to walk away from our
responsibilities should be a generic
route that is what where the government
has fallen down I'm not saying they
should open it immediately because we
have so much irregular movement
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator well I've been exploring taboo
topics and one of those topics that will
so far get you called a bigger far-right
hard right racist and apparently this
week also a homophobe is the issue of
immigration and Suella bravaman has just
done a speech in America which has
captured the imagination and the
Ayah of the nation and so to discuss it
and discuss
the state of immigration in the UK I
have the pleasure of speaking with
author of the books the British dream
success and success and failures of
post-war immigration which celebrates
its 10-year anniversary to this year
uh head hand heart this this struggle
for dignity and status in 21st century
and the absolutely superb and seminal
the road to somewhere the populist
revolt and the future of politics uh it
is of course David goodheart David thank
you so much for joining me thank you for
the invitation Winston uh well uh it's
I'm normally sort of uh try and
ease my guests into it but I thought I'd
start with a a tough question for you
um how is the amateur acapella group
going
well I'm hoping to form one with you as
the as the Meister yeah
um in the in the next few weeks um no
I've I've been in a couple of singing
groups in my time and I I'm I'm looking
to form a new one and you're a musician
and uh you enjoy singing so yeah
Acapella by the way can mean pretty well
anything these days I went just a whole
lot of people getting together and
singing men and women instruments or not
um have you got an idea of the
repertoire you want us to be kind of
um anything really you know pop music
um
um so it really seems like you've given
this a lot of thought every time I bump
into you you mention that you want to
start this group uh but now I'm pressing
you on it it seems like it's maybe not
uh something that you're so serious
about but anyway that's maybe something
for another type um so I want to talk
about sowella's speech and uh she in
which she says that
illegal immigration and immigration is
an existential threat to the West do you
think
that she is correct with this year a
million net migrants forecast to arrive
in the UK in 2022 330
000 illegal immigrants into the EU 2.6
million illegal immigrants into the U.S
and 45
000 illegal immigrants into the UK is
migration illegal immigration in
existential threat to the West
um I mean existential threat so it's a
little bit hyperbolic but uh it is it's
it's a massive issue and it's a massive
issue partly because
divides electorates and it divides the
the voters in Liberal Western
democracies
um not quite down the middle of probably
most countries two-thirds or
three-quarters of people probably think
that
um certainly in the high immigration
countries like like Britain France
Germany uh that immigration is too high
that Society is changing too fast and
but the kind of most influential quarter
or a third of the population
uh either don't go along with that or
feel that the the cost of restricting
immigration both legal and illegal
Asylum Refugee immigration is too high
um so but
you know as the numbers have risen again
this year uh I mean we're not yet back
to anything like the level in Europe
that we had in 2015 after Syria but the
numbers are
creeping back up and uh you know have
had this dramatic episode in lampedusa
the Italian island in the Mediterranean
where eleven thousand Africans just
arrived was it last week
and the significance of that is or not
only the fact that eleven thousand uh
people arriving in lampetusa is larger
than the population of lamp producer
itself which I think is about six or
seven thousand uh caused a huge crisis
in uh in Italian politics
um Ursula uh fonlain
um the uh the EU leader turned up to
give her support to Maloney
um curious enough a little sort of in
parenthesis it's created a sort of
division within
um the new right in Europe between
um Marine Le Pen and and Maloney as to
how one should I want to try and combat
this issue Marine the penis has
basically given up on the EU she says
the EU is just immigrationist
um whereas Maloney is still hoping for
support but the the real significance in
a way I think of the of the lamp
producer
um episode is it shows just how
difficult it is going to be not
impossible but just how difficult it's
going to be to restrict movement across
the Mediterranean from North Africa
because the EU had just signed a deal
with Tunisia which is where the people
were coming from
um I think eventually it was going to
pay out about
um half a billion or a billion euros I
think that they'd formally agreed 100
million euros to precisely to stop this
kind of movement and yet it happened
like weeks after they had signed this
agreement I mean this could be
you know a clever negotiating move on
the part of the Tunisian government to
to just to emphasize what an important
Gateway they are and how important it is
perhaps pay them 2 billion euros rather
than one billion euros who knows
um but I mean across Europe obviously
that the numbers have been going up
um quite sharply and the sense that
democratic governments
are left kind of wringing their hands
because of the way I mean the supplies
in in the UK as much if not more than
anywhere else that the liberalization of
the rules uh that govern the movement of
refugees and Asylum Seekers basically
makes it very difficult to stop people
coming uh once they're here it makes it
very very difficult to to deport them
um a hence our government has has taken
a different track
um because of the the embarrassment of
having 45 000 people a year coming
across the channel I mean it's it's it's
just the partly the visibility of it I
mean when 45 000 people are coming on
lorries or through overstaying visas it
doesn't become such a big political
issue but when you have that challenge
to the common sense citizens idea that
you know we belong to a nation state one
of the definitions of a nation state is
that house borders one of the
definitions of democratic government is
that you control those borders and when
you have the inability do that kind of
being rubbed in our faces every day it
does cause great unease and it has led
to our government taking what seems to
many people even people who support what
their their broad intention is the
slightly eccentric idea of sending
people to an African state that most
people remember as the site of a of a
terrible genocide within living memory
um Rwanda yeah Rwanda
um David you mentioned that the Tunisia
um pact preceding that lampedusa
situation similar things happened where
the conservative government since 2018
when the stop the boats sort of pledge
began there was the UK France joint
action plan Journey 2019 first UK France
joint statement in November 2020 second
UK France joint statement 20 July 21 the
nationality and borders act April 2022
first scheduled Rwanda flight in June
2022 third UK France joint statement
November 22 the promise to stop the
boats in January 283 and the illegal my
Immigration Act this year and in that
time we've had 108 000 illegal
immigrants like all of these packs and
Deals it seems like nothing's actually
being done firstly has the conservative
government just completely
messed up this entire thing has it they
well it's a very difficult situation
it's faced with a kind of a legal
structure
um and a a and also a sort of
semi-dysfunctional home office
um and to be fair to it it has come up
with this idea that this Rwanda idea
which um obviously immensely
controversial although we get support
from a majority of people in Britain it
is now being looked at by other European
countries
um uh you know and uh and and things
that are definitely shifting in Europe
you know you have the do you support the
Rwanda deal well
um I I support the principle behind it I
think there's nothing wrong with saying
you cannot come to the country of your
choice if you are in danger you are
suffering persecution uh then you need
to be in safety you don't need to be in
safety in Shepherd's Bush and you know
if you're coming here we can decide
where the safe place is I mean in the
longer run I've actually just just
written a piece for the think tank that
I um work at part-time policy exchange
on safe and legal routes when we
basically need to turn around the whole
assumptions
Refugee and Asylum needs to become like
legal immigration we basically decide
who comes here that is much much fairer
than the current free-for-all as
everybody emphasizes you know 70 80
percent of people who come across the
channel are are fit young men you have
to be a fit young man to survive the
journey often and you have to come from
a relatively well-off family you know
we're talking about the the middle class
in poor countries basically people who
can afford five or ten thousand dollars
to get themselves male as well male yeah
um
and you know that is a survival of the
fittest darwinian system I mean it's
sort of it's sort of peculiar in some
ways that the the people on the left are
supporting supporting the system people
on the left should be supporting a
regulated controlled system in which we
choose Western governments choose people
from unhcr camps or unhcr registers add
in as indeed we did uh in the Syria
Refugee regime back between 2015 and
2020 we took in not about that money it
was about 20 000 people over five or six
years but it worked really well and they
were placed in specific communities
around the country and yes and we had a
really you know a proper
um relationship between central
government and local authorities and
it's all worked extremely well
um that was Community sponsorship
um that was no that was that was
essentially organized by the by the
national local state here
um
um but actually one of the things I'm
proposing is that yeah yes in the by the
way we have something the government
rightly emphasizes we have actually
taken about half a million people since
2015 through safe and legal routes
obviously the big majority being the
ukrainians in the last year and a half
and the Hong kongers we also have the an
Afghan scheme and this Syria scheme and
some and some Tiddly little schemes as
well let's talk about the safe and legal
groups because this is something that
gets a lot of of pushback as you
mentioned I think we've had 180 000
ukrainians 140 000 Hong kongers and the
safe and legal routes are the the UK
resettlement scheme Community
sponsorship and mandate scheme which as
far as I can find out there was 904
people tiny yeah yeah exactly in the
year ending so that's absolutely tiny so
then you have the refugee family reunion
visas uh which is another
um way way in but apart from that you
can't even get if you you wouldn't be
able to get on a flight here so what
what are they are those real do you
think that there's an enough being done
for safe and legal routes to come to the
UK I mean I I think it's it's just a
matter of timing and Alignment I mean I
think I think it's perfectly
understandable that the government
um is not doing this at the moment when
so many people are coming through
illegal routes uh irregular routes
um so I think you know you need to have
that under control before you start uh
opening up these safe and legal routes
but you can start talking about them now
and I think one of the one of the
failures with the government
presentation on this is that they open
they're open to the accusation that has
come constantly from the refugee
organizations that yeah it's all very
well to talk about the the half a
million safe and legal routes but those
are all country specific but there is no
generic safe and legal route for a
Christian in Pakistan who faces
persecution a gay person in Iran who
faces persecution or whatever that is
what they say and it is a reasonable
point and the government should say when
we get the irregular entry this unfair
free-for-all irregular entry under
control we will have a system that we
will and we will decide every year what
the cap should be and that'll depend on
other flows and so on but you know we'll
have a cap of twenty thousand thirty
thousand a year we will do our bit for
the global Refugee problem and we will
have a system like the Syria scheme
where we get the unhcr or we could have
our own people out there collaborating
with unhcr as Canada does to select
people and then you could you can select
the people who are who are most in
danger who are most threatened uh by the
Taliban or or whatever or who who are
most
um or who are most vulnerable who have
the most
um the the the most difficult medical
conditions or whatever
um and it'll mainly mainly be Women and
Children Well in some ways this uh what
what the Afghan Ukrainian and Hong konga
schemes is a version of that is being
specifically targeting groups but that
still hasn't appeased the opponents of
well as I say because they say there
isn't a generic route it's all very well
you know you you have these specific
country regions what if you are uh you
know a Christian you don't think it's
going to be a generic group yes I'm
saying there should be a generic route
that is what where the government has
fallen down I'm not saying they should
open it immediately because we have so
much irregular movement at the moment
but they should be talking about when
they make speeches
um and I'm generic I think has mentioned
it in in a couple of his speeches but
they should be saying you know when we
get this under control we're not just
going to walk away from our
responsibilities we have you know we're
a big you know liberal globally
um outward-looking country and all that
um we you know we need to do our part
and this is what we are planning to do
so we're going to have a generic
uh safe and legal route that we will we
will go and select people from the unhcr
register and you know we'll select the
most vulnerable and we'll bring in 20 30
000 a year or whatever it is we might I
also propose that we should have for
those there is a small number of people
who really are in immediate danger
obviously very few people who are coming
from northern France into Britain
they're not in a meeting or none but
there are you know there are people who
face you know they're like there was a
famous Christian uh woman in Pakistan a
few years ago who was who was prosecuted
for blasphemy and she was going to be
executed
um and there was an attempt to get her
out by uh Sajid jabard I think in the
end she went to Canada she which she was
but you know there's a very small number
of people who are in absolute desperate
straights like that
um and there perhaps ought to be some
sort of special red route for them that
you could have a kind of ad hoc
Committee of the of the you know
Security Services in the foreign office
and local ambassadors and so on um but
that but that would always be I think a
pretty number
um you know you're talking more about
these large these millions of people
who've been displaced because of
conflicts who are living uh either in
different parts of their own country or
in a neighboring country and some of
them some of them really would benefit
from coming to a Western Country many of
them can be better helped where they are
I mean that that is also uh Syrian
um strategy as well yeah
um
and there was a very good book a few
years ago
um I I forget the uh the authors now but
um
um in in which they talked about you
know the importance of making making
refugee camps sort of tolerable places
where you know not only do they have
health clinics and schools and so on but
places where people actually work places
can where people can actually sort of
create a life and also they then remain
quite close to the the country of origin
they understand what the position is but
you know if the conflict has died down
perhaps they can go home and so on
rather than this assumption that you
know as soon as somebody faces a
difficulty in a far away country they
should be you know coming to live in
Stockport
um
um you know it's it's it's unfair it
creates an unbalanced world we need you
know these places need to develop and
they're often losing their most their
brightest and most energetic and
ambitious people they're the people who
are on the boats crossing the channel
um so so we need a generic safe and
legal route as well as the country
specific ones once we've got irregular
movement
um uh more under control
um but we also I mean the other big
development I mean so one one recent
model is the the Syria scheme that we
had between 2015 and 2020 uh you know a
a generic version of that
the other thing that we've had of course
is the as you mentioned is the homes for
Ukraine scheme which was 120 000 British
people
um accepted into their home ukrainians
now admittedly it was dramatic we were
you know these are people you know who
are kind of like us to some extent
they're within the you know live within
the kind of broad European space uh and
we were seeing that they were being
bummed out of their homes every night on
television so it was a huge amount of
sympathy
um you know those things don't
necessarily apply to most of the world's
refugees but um but what did show is
that the the sort of skepticism I think
of of kind of Whitehall officials that
that you know ordinary British people
can can actually step up and and look
after uh look after refugees for for a
year or two
um their skepticism I think was was was
proven wrong
um and we should really tap into that
because I think the anxieties people
have about
particularly irregular immigration I
mean people generally think that you
know the the kind of relaxed view about
immigration that we had after
post-brexit the feeling that
um that free movement had ended and
anxiety about immigration did decline
quite substantially it popped right back
up again partly because we because legal
migration is now at such an
extraordinary high level you know 600
000 net uh uh a year and of course we
have the boats which is this sort of
constant aggravating factor which
reminds people that our governments are
impotent when it comes to to controlling
our our borders you know before brexit
we're I think it hit 330 000 net
migration yeah was the maximum legal
migrants into the UK well now we're at
like 600 hitting a million it's
forgetting we're not hitting a million
no I mean that's wrong I mean it's going
to come down not up uh net migrations up
but why is it coming down should we come
back to okay legal migration a bit later
okay where where oh yes we were talking
about homes Ukraine
um
so notwithstanding the fact that there
is much greater anxiety about
immigration in general I think there are
particular anxieties that people have
about irregular migration one is the
enormous cost now you might say that's
partly government stroke home office
incompetence the fact that we've allowed
this huge backlog to develop with the
you know eight million pounds a day in
hotels four billion pounds in general
last year
but cost uh integration issues and
security issues you know when someone is
coming on a boat it's much much harder
to sort of screen them in case they have
you know connections to
um you know unsavory organizations or
whatever
um now
if you I mean the homes for Ukraine
scheme has sort of set a new template in
a way
um for the uh the way in which we could
accommodate uh refugees so if we
assuming a new system under which we're
selecting most refugees are La Syria
scheme
um then when they come here uh instead
of instead of sitting in hotels they are
distributed around the country by by
people of good will you know there are
lots of people who are very very
pro-refugee will let them you know put
their money where their mouth is let
them step up as many of them did in the
case of Ukraine and say we will take uh
I mean not necessarily living in their
homes but we will help them we will you
know help them with you know English
conversation classes or whatever you
know tap into that good will that is out
there
um so that helps to reduce the cost
um and also the other factor is
um that the government should be looking
to Diaspora organizations I mean why is
the you know the British Afghan Council
or the British Iranian Association why
these organizations not being asked to
step up
um in you know in the way that people
did with Ukrainian I mean you know what
what their their co-nationals who are
coming here you know we could say uh you
know Iran is is a is a is a is a pretty
Dreadful Theocratic State you know quite
a few people coming across the channel
are uh you know Iranian doctors who
don't want to live in a Theocratic State
well you know we could say
um we will take 2 000 uh you know they
have to obviously be outside the country
I mean that obviously they have left the
country and come to northern France in
order to get on a boat to come here but
they would have to be registered with
the unhcr somewhere outside Iran
um the British Iranian Association could
say right we're going to take 2 000
Iranian with two two thousands of our
co-nationals this year
um you know get the unhcr to provide us
with the the 2000 Iranians who most need
um to live in a safe Western Country
um that's a practical way of
implementing exactly describing earlier
yeah so it's the idea sorry the the
concept that I was I was looking for I
was sponsorship you know I mean that is
what
um you know we have these you mentioned
them earlier we have these schemes but
they they've been you know they've been
left to rot now I mean nobody comes
through them that's partly because so
many people have been coming through
irregular routes so the government has
had no incentive at all to advertise the
fact that you have you can have
Community sponsorship so
um I don't know say you know
um churches have been unorthodox
Community yeah in West London or a
Jewish or a Muslim Community or whatever
with an attachment to a particular
original country can say you know we
will we will put up some some money we
will find places for people to live
um and that deals at a stroke with both
the the kind of financial anxiety that
people have about these large numbers
coming uh and the and the integration
and security angles so if you had more
sponsorship either that General sort of
individual sponsorship that you had in
the case of home so you brain or more
likely Community sponsorship or family
sponsorship you know lots of people here
who have who have relations you know who
are who are in Dire Straits somewhere
you know they could appeal to have them
put on the list of people who come here
via the safe and legal route and then
again the costs are kept down and the
integration aspect is dealt with and the
security aspect can I challenge you on
the homes for Ukraine scheme as a
reflection of what's really going on
because with that scheme and I worked on
it so I I saw it in action
we thought that the war was going to
last three to six months so we thought
we were taking just women and children
and that it would be a short program and
that they would go home afterward that
is completely different let's say to the
Hong Kong program which I've also been
working on which
was those Hong kongers they had no
intention of going back to Hong Kong
they are they are moving here for good
that is incent even though you you can
see it as a kind of it is certainly a
political crisis in Hong Kong that is an
economic migration of sorts
um it's it's a it's a it's a blurring of
of the two and I don't think what
happened in Ukraine truly reflects the
appetite for Brits for for immigration
I look I'm not sure I mean as I just
said you know there's the the the
skepticism about large-scale migration
wherever it comes from whether it's
legal or irregular has gone right back
up again you know we're in in the kind
of high 60s of people who think that
immigration is too high
um and I agree but we're talking about a
sort of subset of the population you
know we're talking about the guardian
reading classes
um although actually I saw some um data
on
Party Support among people who were
taking the roughly 120 000 people who
stepped up to take people I think it's a
bit less than 120 000 actually and it
was kind of reasonably well distributed
across the three main parties like
nearly 30 of Tories a bit more labor and
uh and and lib Dem perhaps so you get um
um so so the the two things are not are
not necessarily in Conflict I mean I
would challenge you slightly on that I
think the Hong Kong story is slightly
more complicated I think a lot of people
uh have have taken their
um their right to get British residency
as a kind of insurance policy you know I
mean life in Hong Kong still goes on and
there are you know there's a relatively
High degree of business Freedom you may
not speak your mind politically but you
know people over there live there all
their lives they they don't necessarily
want to leave unless they really have to
unless things get really really heavy
um and obviously some people will look
of that 140 000 I think you know I don't
know maybe maybe
um perhaps a half two-thirds have come
to live here permanently I think others
are kind of yo-yoing a bit or certainly
I've known some who've gone back to Hong
Kong even but they're not I would say of
the 140 000 it's a very slim amount of
them who have who are actually fleeing
direct persecution from this issue yeah
yeah and of course that raises the kind
of awkward issue of integration in the
fact that of course some groups are
easier to integrate than other groups
um something that um you know people
don't really like to well let's talk
about that because it is an awkward
thing
um you know
um you know we had
um what is it 175 000 180 000 ukrainians
came over in the blinking of an eye and
and 120 000 Brits stepped up to I mean
we would not that would not be the case
with Afghans I mean or people from uh
poorer more traditional parts of the
world and apart from anything else
Afghans tend to have very large families
so you know if you're talking about you
know a one you Ukrainian woman with a
with a child or two children it's a very
very different thing from uh and also
it's quite likely that that Ukrainian
woman will speak some if not quite good
English whether compare that with an
Afghan family of four or six
um much more traditional Norms
um you know when it comes to religiosity
relations between men and women or you
know we're talking about huge huge
cultural Gulfs yeah
um now obviously that isn't an issue
with no one talks about the Hong kongers
because you know they just kind of blend
in they're uh there may be particular
parts of London where there's a
disproportionate number of them but
there are no sort of areas of big cities
in the way that you get with uh with
lots of other uh minorities in the UK uh
the Hong Kongos that's because there's a
couple of reasons for that firstly is
they were wearing as a Hong Kong you're
sort of wearing two hats anyway one is a
British hat and one is a is a Hong Kong
hat which is a mixture yeah sorry rather
the Hong Kong hat is kind of a half
British half Chinese hat that they're
wearing so they are pre they are that
it's a country that that didn't exist
until Britain created it yeah and so
they have culturally they are they are
sort of half British yeah so their
political culture is
quite very close to us closer to us than
it is to the CCP but also of the ones
who came over a lot of them with
Christian a disproportionate amount were
Christian compared to and they tend to
be middle class they tend to be educated
they speak you know English sometimes as
a first language I mean or certainly
exactly well or fluent you know quasi
fluently so uh you know obviously a lot
of those a lot of the normal linguistic
or cultural barriers to integration just
don't apply in their case so they're not
noticed and indeed you know they could
be an enormous boost to the British
economy something I mean I don't think
the obr are kind of taking this into
account but I mean if we end up with you
know over the next two or three years
250 300 000 Hong kongers you know who
are kind of quietly getting on opening
businesses you know you know raising the
the sort of educational and
entrepreneurial capital of the country I
mean you know they might put half a
percent on GDP um
I mean whereas you know most other forms
of irregular migration or tend to be the
reverse I mean they tend to be a drag on
on uh you know that it's very hard for
the people to
um to contribute significantly
economically so that they're dependent
on welfare often and as I say they come
from traditional parts of the world and
they are often have very big families uh
you know that they're they're consuming
more in public services and Welfare than
they are yeah
in Her speech is that they don't well
it's very hard for them to to contribute
I mean you know many of them will do uh
in the longer run
um but um yeah no I mean I mean of
course one one of the we have to also be
realistic about the fact that you know
my idea of of having a generic and
a generic safe and legal route uh you
know perhaps alongside some continuing
country specific ones
um as I say all of this is premised on
getting the irregular movement largely
under control but you know when and if
that is done uh you can start thinking
about these safe and legal routes but
one of the problems with the safe and
legal route is that you know if you if
you have the kind of power of God if you
have the power of selection you tend to
take the most vulnerable and the most
needy so
um
even if you know we're taking 25 or 30
000 people from the unhcr register uh
these are people who on the whole are
not going to be economic contributors at
least for quite a few years I mean their
children maybe
um but they are probably not going to be
economic contributors unlike the young
men coming across the channel on the
boats you know who are
um they are you know kind of ready and
willing to work and do that that's one
of the reasons they're coming here is
that they they want to
um they want to live in a wealthy
country and they don't want to be
sitting at home on welfare
um so it is it is one of the costs as it
were of controlling the system uh is
that in the medium term the economic
costs may actually be slightly higher
but on the other hand if you've
controlled it then you're not spending
four billion pounds a year on
um on Refugee costs or irregular
irregular
of course can I ask you a question which
is sort of for any Progressive listeners
that I might have still retained uh is
that it's the issue of multiculturalism
and this we saw this at least an Annie
making a defense of it on question time
last week
um do you think uh
Angela Merkel said that multicolor
culturalism had failed David Cameron had
said and yet people are still defending
it do you think multiculturalism has
failed
it all depends of course what you mean
by multiculturalism and that's part of
the problem with this debate is that uh
and it is interesting that that was the
part of the suela Brahman speech that
was most picked up on uh because much of
the rest of it was used just as it were
restating uh government policy or things
that she's already said but it was her
you know her her reflecting the the kind
of Miracle Cameron skepticism but what
she is using multiculturalism uh I think
in in a sort of more accurate sense than
most of her critics most of her critics
hear the word multiculturalism and they
they actually hear
multi-ethnicity they hear that they hear
her criticizing the fact that we're a
multi-ethnic society I mean virtually
nobody uh is saying we
can't be a multi-ethnic society or we
should reverse it I mean it's something
like three percent of the population
think that you have to be white to be
truly British I mean that kind of
racialized idea of a you know of a
purely white Britain uh you know it's
held by a tiny tiny proportion of the
population
multiculturalism uh is you know is an
idea origin came out of Canada and in
the in the kind of 1950s it's the idea
um and particularly the way it's been
applied in the UK
um is a kind of you can come here and be
yourself
uh
uh that and and it sort of flowed in
some ways
um quite automatically from a kind of
almost a colonial mentality
um you know you know British people had
gone out to Africa and India and other
parts of the world uh and had maintained
pretty strict sort of racial ethnic
um divisions and um when we had the um
the the nationality act in 1948 which
basically provided an open door to
everybody in the Empire and Commonwealth
uh right up until 1962 I mean that is
when most non-white immigration really
took off on a large scale in the UK in
those in those early years
um before the door was sort of half shut
although actually non-white immigration
continued uh even at higher levels in
some years after 1962 but so that it was
that sort of almost sort of colonial
assumption that when people came here I
mean it was a kind of a mixture of sort
of Common Sense and and a colonial
mentality the idea uh that that
um what's the word there's a technical
term for it um
um
basically you know people are more
comfortable with people like themselves
homophily homophily
um uh that you're you know your your um
your you you want to live among people
who you share and language and culture
and way of life with
um and and that obviously is true
um and so it there was going to be uh
there was always going to be a sort of
clustering when when people came to live
here
um what I think in retrospect we got
wrong
um is that we were sort of too lazy Fair
we went we had a kind of laissez-faire
liberal stroke Colonial version of
multiculturalism which said
um you know it's fine to come here and
and live separately so long as you can
obey the law and pay your taxes it was
just an absolutely minimalist
um notion of multiculturalism and of
course this is this is often contrasted
with the French approach I mean on the
ground there wasn't a huge amount of
difference actually between what's
happening in in Britain and France uh we
apart from numbers but
um yeah I mean France had a lot of
people coming from this North African
colonies uh in in the same era
um but they had this they had this
rhetoric of integration where all French
people you know and this led to various
sort of rather weird things like they so
they they don't really know what the
condition of their ethnic minority
populations in France because they're
not allowed to collect data about but
because everybody is just French you
know whatever you look like whatever
your religion or background you are you
know you're we're all one under the
marseillaise kind of thing
um now obviously that didn't uh that I
mean they have integration problems that
are as great if not greater than ours
um
but we didn't
um we we didn't sort of say to people
when they come yes come here and be
yourself up to a point but you are now
living in Britain and these are the
rules and you know we would like you to
kind of join in the society and and some
groups did that and some groups didn't
um and or or not sufficiently
um you know we there are different
things one could focus on I mean there's
the linguistic aspect I mean most people
obviously second generation Brits from
whatever background
um you know speak English is there
usually it's their mother tongue but
there are still some you know older
women often from
um sanitation backgrounds who uh who
tended not to mix in society so never
spoke English well uh that was an issue
the the I mean just the sort of over
concentration of certain groups in
certain areas
um the big culture Rule and value divide
between perhaps particularly between
devout religious perhaps particularly
Muslims
um the problem they're probably the
biggest group in the UK with very strong
religiosity and often as I said earlier
with very traditional views about
relations between men and women
um you know these things have have
caused tension uh you know if you and
you look at a place like Leicester
Leicester has become a focus of of uh of
concern about well a focus of discussion
about the Multicultural you know is
multiculturalism working well or not you
know well you know I I spend quite a lot
of time in Leicester before while I was
writing my uh British dream book that
you mentioned that 10 years ago
um and
um Lester is is both a success and a
failure in some ways I mean it
it's a success if you set the bar quite
low and I think this is yet another of
the disservices that Enoch Powell and
his famous speech
um did for for British politics he set
the bar you know so long as you know the
River Thames is not sort of you know
flowing with with blood then we're we're
doing okay you know because Enoch Pearl
has been proved wrong there is not
um you know a great physical violence
between different ethnic groups in
Britain therefore everything is fine
well uh that is that is setting the bar
ridiculously low
um but yeah there has been some physical
violence yeah yeah um whether not
between whites and non-whites on all
that's between Lester seeks and Muslims
exactly yeah um well that's what I was
going to say I mean you know Lester I
mean I haven't been quite surprised when
I went to Leicester you know back in
probably there in 2011 2012 and it was
you know heralded is a great success
story of of multiculturalism and it was
it is a very divided town in in the
neighborhoods that people you know there
there's a kind of wide working class
Estates there is a kind of Hindu area
there's a Muslim area you know there are
gujaratis there are different you know
and there's a there's a small black
Caribbean area I seem to remember you
know you have I mean there are some
areas probably the more middle class
areas tend to be a bit more mixed
um there's um there's the area just
outside Leicester that I went to that uh
it's like sort of Hampstead it's sort of
in the semi-country side
um I can't remember the name of it but
it was like full of the
um you know Indian Heritage Consultants
who worked at the local hospital you
know who who mixed perfectly happily
with the affluent white people who you
know who lived in lived in the um these
sort of rural suburbs of of the city
um but in the city itself you get these
you know huge divisions and and the fact
that nobody ever seemed to think that
there was an issue with that I suppose
um is a reflection of the sort of late
safe liberal multiculturalism model that
we adopted
um and you know you could say it works
up to a point everybody everybody keeps
to themselves except perhaps in various
sort of sub Elites but a lot of the kind
of ordinary people in all of those
different groups probably don't mix
friendship groups won't
um no this may be this may be improving
amongst younger Generations but you know
if you go to school in a you know
overwhelmingly white area if you're in
overwhelmingly Muslim area you know all
your friends are going to be you know
that's why actually University often
ends up being uh
um in the in those parts of Britain
University ends up being a very
important
point of integration because often you
know you won't have you won't have met
um you know you come from certain
communities you won't have met or
certainly been friends with uh with
white people until you get to University
and then
um and then you tend to get more more
mixing
um but as you say uh you know the the
the last uh model
um was never uh I think in some ways a
very attractive model
um it was peace it was more or less
peaceful but now as you say you've seen
this conflict between uh Hindus and
Muslims
um and
um or you could cite the the recent
um who are in Peckham uh you know kind
of you know angry black mob turns up
outside of uh Asian pharmacist shop
um and this guy's now in hiding I mean
that there are you know there are
historic tensions between uh between
Asians and blacks in in many cities the
Asians are often landlords or small shop
owners
um
um often very mistrustful of their Black
customers and so on and that that's
built out in Peckham a few
a few weeks ago but I think you know the
the Leicester
you know the Leicester story you can
look at it through either lens in a way
um but I think
um I think we could have done better
there could have been a more conscious
effort to mix people up there was
actually initially back in the back in
the kind of early 60s there were very
sort of uh British versions of bussing
um but they proved pretty unpopular as
they were in America so they stopped um
but it's you know I mean because people
go to school in the places they live you
know that you can't you perpetuate those
differences often yeah you say we could
have done better though so would you
like there to be a change in approach by
by government to integration
I mean different standards should there
be obligations to learn English should
there be uh you know the extreme example
might be Singapore where you you weren't
they didn't want different groups yeah
different places so they integrated
integrated in living public housing
exactly yeah I think I think that's sort
of too illiberal for us
um I mean
you know every now and then I mean it
used to be the case whenever there was a
sort of terrorist attack by British
Muslims you know there'd be a wave of
anxiety uh there'd be a new report on
integration there'd be a new phrases
parallel lives you know it came up in
the uh in the early 2000s and we had the
um
uh more recent report
uh when was it six or seven years ago uh
and I mean Trump you know in it's very
difficult to enforce integration in a
liberal Society
um uh you know politicians could perhaps
talk about it a bit more I mean I think
local authorities I mean I think
what you could do is
um encourage local authorities to
encourage more mixed neighborhoods and
mixed schools and there have been
various attempts to do this
um and
um you can you know data helps here
enormously I mean you know if if every
year or every couple of years you were
publishing data on the degree of
segregation in different local
authorities the local authorities you
know wherever it is in Blackburn or um
or uh or or
Burnley or um or older more or you know
some of these
um northern towns where there is
continues to be quite uh high levels of
segregation uh you know if you publish
figures on schools and
um and neighborhoods uh you know the
people who are at the bottom of the list
you know the most segregated no one
wants to be called the most segregated
local Authority in Britain so they would
that you would you would encourage you
know even if Innovative local thinking
about this now I mean it may be that
um that generational change is
uh uh is helping to deal with some of
these things and of course as people
have become the more successful groups
as they've moved out of their original
um their sort of areas of residence in
in London or in even in the northern
Mill towns they've tended to tended to
move into more middle class areas where
um where where there is more mixing in
schools and places so affluence
couldn't sort of help to have a time
also you know white British people get
more used to you know having I think
minority people in their town or you
know on the TV or whatever I mean and
that so you know anyone who's you know
under 50 in Britain is just you know
used to
um you know High degree of sort of
multi-ethnicity in their in their lives
um and actually it's interesting in the
Leicester case that one of the kind of
there have been various analyzes of the
punch-up
um last year
um and a lot of people were saying it
was the recent immigrants from India and
and Pakistan perhaps it was the the
Hindu Muslim
um
immigrants of kind of recent stock who
were behind the conflict so it was not
you know you know the you know the the
people who have been here for for years
or perhaps were born here
um uh you know do know how to get on
with each other and with the majority
White Community oh and it was these it
was these newcomers who sort of didn't
didn't get the rules but but you know as
you were saying earlier I mean there are
a lot of these newcomers uh in recent
years so you know we might well find
ourselves with more of these uh kind of
conflicts that we saw in Leicester
uh if I can pull it back because swella
Braven has asked for Thought leaders
like yourself to put their minds to the
uh rethinking of the 1951 U.N Refugee
convention which is being abused she
claims because it's woolly in uh
definitions of uh let's say words like
persecution discrimination so far to the
extent that when she was challenged in
an interview she said that homosexual
homosexuality could be abused as a way
of coming uh you can claim your escaping
persecution because you're gay and Elton
John has pushed back against that saying
it will encourage uh discrimination
against gays in turn uh do you think um
there needs to be a rewriting of of that
uh I was slightly surprised what she
picked on I mean I mean the legal
framework in general does make it very
difficult to control your borders I mean
that is the truth whether it's the
Refuge nomination of the refugee
convention and the echr the European
convention on human rights make it very
very difficult
to control borders I'm not sure that the
um the refugee convention
should be the main target I mean I think
actually it's much more the European
convention on human rights and
particularly the Clause that talks about
um
degrading and in human treatment that
you should not send anywhere anyone back
to somewhere where they might be subject
to that
um but you asked me at the at the uh at
the beginning what I thought of the
Rwanda scheme and I never really
answered them and I do think
um I mean ultimately you can only stop
these movements with agreement
um of between nations
um like in the case of Australia you
know they had an agreement to stop boats
coming and return them to
yeah um you know we could stop the boats
coming over in the blinking of an eye if
we had an agreement with the French and
everybody that comes over we just sent
back to France the boats would stop
tomorrow for all sorts of reasons France
won't do that although it's still
possible in the longer run that that
will be the way that we will stop the
boats it won't be the way we'll stop uh
or all movement but it will probably
require some sort of agreement with
France if the Rwanda scheme doesn't work
now the Rwanda scheme I mean I think
um is it offshoring or Outsourcing I
almost forget
um I mean that the uh I think we've
basically outsourced the whole system to
Rwanda which I think may not be the best
way to go I think there is absolutely
nothing wrong in principle with us as it
were calling people's Bluff you know if
you're coming here because your life is
threatened then
um we will we will protect you but we
will you but you you can't decide where
you're going to live and uh and actually
I'm afraid you know you're not going to
come here unless you have a particular
reason to be talking earlier about you
know family sponsorship and so on
um that door ought to be open but
otherwise you
um we're gonna we're gonna take you to a
safe place
um and of course people don't want that
because that's not you know they want to
be in a rich country and they want to as
it were short circuit the historical
process it's going to take another
several Generations before you know
their lives the you know Eritrea or
Somalia or whatever are going to be
decent places to live
um and you know they're they've got
they're from a better or family they've
got the resources they're gonna they're
gonna hop over here if they can
um but there's nothing particularly
Progressive about that uh it's slowing
down the changes that ought to be coming
in those countries and so if they come
here we should say okay we will keep you
safe
um and uh Rwanda uh recent anyway I
think has a broadly perfectly good
record on that what I I'm a little bit
um not historically but yeah exactly but
I mean partly because of that historical
memory uh and they know that the eyes of
the world are on them uh they actually I
think have a reasonably good record
um
um and indeed I think the unhcr itself
has talked about sending refugees to
Rwanda so um I'm in Rwanda because of
what happened there is obviously
um you know sort of somewhat
um sort of difficult difficult for
people to digest
um
but I think we should be controlling the
whole processing of people I mean I
think what I'm slightly uneasy about in
the case of the Rwanda thing is that
we've we've subcontracted the whole
process to them
um but of course you know if the Rwanda
scheme works and they have the capacity
uh then you create an immediate
disincentive it's like my example of
France I mean as soon as you have an
agreement with France and send people
back no one no one's going to waste ten
thousand dollars their you know their
families hard-earned savings
um if they're just gonna be sent back to
where they don't want to be
um so you know the whole point about the
Rwanda idea is it's a it's a it's a
disincentive you don't have to Romana
doesn't have to be full of 150 000
refugees who wanted to come to Britain I
mean it might have to be full of five
thousand
um but so long as it's done rigorously
um then then you me you know you you
dissuade people from making the journey
here anyway not necessarily making the
Journey full stop and you know to
dissuade people from making the Journey
full stop well you just you need some
version of
um I think perhaps call it offshoring
rather than Outsourcing for the whole of
Europe
um Europe needs to so anyone who arrives
you know via in a regular method is
taken to
you know Ascension Island or or wherever
um and uh and they're and they're kept
there safely in a humane way and of
course people won't want that because
people are coming to to enjoy living in
a in a rich country they're not coming
to be safe or not only to be safe
um so you know there are you know some
sort of offshoring system like Rwanda
will probably be adopted I think by you
know the the alternative you know what
the famous saying you know if Liberals
are not going to protect National
borders then people will vote for
illiberals to do it um for them they
won't necessarily be great supporters
the
afd in Germany or the Marine Le Pen or
whatever but they all vote for them if
if they get sufficiently aggravated by
this policy and and then you know if we
don't have an ordered way of stopping it
you know we will have a violent way of
stopping it
um you know the there's this this famous
book
um uh this kind of this sort of racist
dystopian sort of vision that this
french guy Jean raspe had he wrote a
famous book called the camper the Saints
back in the early 1970s and it's uh and
it's sort of predicting in in some ways
what's happening now there's this
enormous boat that I think comes from
somewhere in India in Bengal and it sort
of collects more and more people as it
goes goes around
um the Cape of Good Hope and up the
Atlantic and it's sort of heading for
Marseille
um and I mean it has all this sort of
grotesque you know racist imagery
um
of these of the people on the boat you
know who are coming to destroy Europe
um and um uh you know obviously it's a
it's a novel it's a sort of exaggeration
but I mean you know people get into that
sort of Camp of the Saints mindset then
you know it ends the book ends with an
enormous sort of um violent
conflagration
um so you know we've you know politics
has got to has got to intervene I think
we've had liberal complacency about this
people say oh well you know migration is
impossible to stop
um well that's that's not true we have
shown that you can do it I mean the EU
did it in pushing back when everyone was
coming from Turkey we did a deal with
turkey Australia has done a deal just to
stop it to stop uh stop boats coming uh
it can be done now you know obviously
this needs um you know we need to bribe
countries with uh offers of a lot of
money of legal migration possibilities
you know from the North African States
or you know whoever it is that we we
need to sort of control the movement and
of course we need to help these
countries develop I mean you know Rich
Western countries you know spend a lot
of money on development Aid and
um a lot of that money could perhaps be
spent more effectively but you know we
need
um
we need those countries to get rich
quick I mean when you get Beyond a
certain level the incentive to to move
declines it's it's that sort of
in-between state that we're probably in
for another 20 or 30 years
um I mean leaving aside the whole
question of climate change and whether
that's going to uh affect things or not
um but for the next 20 or 30 years
there'll be a lot of countries that have
developed up to a point and have quite
big middle classes but are still pretty
miserable places to live and that you
know if you have the wherewithal as more
people now do you'll get out
um and um uh you know once they move
um you know if you're either a lot
poorer than that you don't have very
many people can move or you're a bit
richer and and actually it is worth
staying I mean and we've got to
help those countries I guess get to the
get to the point where they
um where the kind of bright and
ambitious people want to stay
well on that note David thank you so
much for coming in to speak with me
congratulations on the anniversary of
your book uh British stream and
um uh where can listeners find you
um well I live in Hampstead
um I'm uh well I work I work part-time
for Polish exchange the think tank and
yeah I'm I guess my sort of Pub I mean
I'm on Twitter I mean I don't have a sub
stack or anything
um but uh yeah I can be reached that by
Twitter wonderful David goodheart thank
you so much for speaking with me all
right
thank you
foreign